[Music]
and welcome to hannity tonight we are
witnessing what is an unprecedented
effort around the country from the
radical socialist democratic party
to fundamentally radically transform
this country in his frail cognitively
struggling state
joe biden the leader might not realize
it but
his administration is now waging what is
an all-out assault
on the principles that have made this
country great as we speak
the democratic party is now plotting a
new court packing scheme to seize
control over the judicial branch of
government
a co-equal branch they're eyeing
statehood for d.c for puerto rico
to guarantee what four new democratic
senators in perpetuity
they are federalizing elections and
prevent
all forms of voter authentication that
means no voter id
whatsoever that's through hr sr1
thus increasing the opportunity for what
fraud abuse
no integrity no confidence in future
elections that will be the result
they want to get rid of the legislative
filibuster why so they can ram
through this radical agenda their bills
through congress
without any republicans support and
their policies will
shred our constitution starting with the
woke canceled culture destroying let's
see the first amendment
the second amendment and pretty much the
entire the entire document
now of course none of this is about
freedom liberty security or innovation
or making your life better for the
leftist is about one thing and one thing
only
don't let anybody don't let anybody
convince you otherwise this is about
power power over our elections power
that
favors them power over our courts that
favors them
power over state legislatures even if
it's
unconstitutional power over state and
local law power over
your life power in perpetuity forever
and ever
and here's the end game the democratic
socialist party ultimately wants
all of america pretty much to resemble
california
and new york high taxes high crime
horrible schools burdensome regulation
massive government corruption
and this is the dream this is what they
tell us
if you like new york and you like
california buckle up because that's what
the united sanctuary socialist states of
america will look like
in new york city if you are a peaceful
law-abiding tax-paying citizen
you better not jaywalk or go 15 miles
over the speed limit
or forget to wear your mask or exercise
god forbid your second amendment rights
you'll go to jail
with probably little hope of ever
getting out but if you're a violent
criminal
unfit for society new york state
welcomes you with open arms
you want to loot you want to attack cops
you want to light a building on fire
let's see throw rocks and bottles and
bricks
molotov cocktails for police well you
get the
get out of jail free card literally with
their new
nobel laws in new york in fact many of
these crimes are
never even prosecuted last year a guy
robbed four banks
got arrested got released right back
onto the streets
then immediately goes to rob another
bank gets caught
gets released then robs another one last
night we showed you this horrific video
a man brutally assaulting a 65 year old
woman
she was walking to church in midtown
manhattan as you can see it's daylight
and by the way pushing her to the
pavement watch the face being stomped on
again
and again the alleged perpetrator was
out on parole
after spending only 17 years behind bars
for murdering his own mother with a
knife why was he ever released
meanwhile in ithaca new york you have a
convicted cop killer
that's right cop killer convicted
recently
paroled from prison now sitting on the
city's police reform board
well that's just genius all across the
country
that we are all witnessing similar
things happening like in california
which is also outlawed cash bail for
those who cannot afford it
the state is also cutting funding for
the lapd
they're downsizing the hardcore gangs
unit
and guess what california is more
violent crime than any other state in
the nation
so if you like california you like new
york you're going to love biden's
socialist utopia
by the way also both are sanctuary
states meaning
they shield even criminal illegal
immigrants
even those that get out of jail for
violent crimes
they are protected by these states from
deportation
and enforcing the law of the land but if
you're a law-abiding
citizen with no criminal record work
hard pay your taxes
obey the laws tries to follow the
regulations
you better mask up you better follow all
of the covent protocols
you get better get all of your required
permits
or you'll probably go straight to jail
and your business could be shut down
you could face serious life-altering
consequences
and god forbid if you want to hold a
church service somewhere
now unless you're california governor
gavin newsom who in the middle of
his stage draconian lockdowns enjoyed
his massless
mass glass dinner at that fancy
restaurant with a large group of friends
doesn't seem too distant to me see when
democrats have all the power
the rules don't apply to their
magnificent leaders
they'll defund the police then they hire
armed guards
they'll shut down the public schools
because of covid and send
their own kids to private schools just
like gavin newsom they'll ban
guns and then enjoy the services of
their own state-backed private security
armed maybe this is why every single
city in the u.s
with a high rate of violent crime is run
by democrats
and has been for decades and when any of
their policies create a major crisis
like for example
the one that is real at our southern
border well democrats just pretend it's
not happening
or that it's totally out of their
control then they accuse anyone who
criticizes them for being
a heartless monster well those
conditions
frankly are heartless that they're
putting these kids in
here's a great example of all of this
from today's press brief
briefing take a look has the white house
considered beefing up border security
now that there is
video of a three-year-old and a
five-year-old being
thrown over the wall in new mexico
beefing up border security well there
are there's video now
of a three-year-old in the fight i've
seen the video and i think any of us who
saw the video
were incredibly alarmed by uh the steps
of smugglers
they still got close enough as you guys
were talking about addressing root
causes in the region for a smuggler to
throw them
over a wall into the desert and i'm just
curious what
the white house is doing to stop that
from happening and
are you concerned more about the kids
safety or are you concerned about kids
getting in
or tell me more about your concern here
kid safety is
as you've just mentioned the main
concern well of course it is which is
why i'm
often surprised by some of the line of
questioning in here
circle back gensake why are you
surprised you saw the kid look at these
kids being dropped 14 feet up in the air
maybe you and the president and vice
president
should have not invited those to seek
asylum
in the united states you're letting all
of these people
in as was recorded by 19 u.s senators
and by the way what are the conditions
like maybe you should tell the people
that our borders are closed
our laws will be enforced they will be
deported and deported immediately
then maybe finish building donald
trump's wall
then maybe reinstate donald trump's
policy which is stay in mexico
and get rid of catch and release but we
all know that's not going to happen
is it that you think they care that kids
are being tossed over the wall
it's happening because they created this
scenario what about the kids in biden's
cages
think they really care about any of
those conditions in those migrant
detention facilities
yup joe biden just keeps building more
and more cages
as you can see if you ran a day care
center if you ran
a pre-k center and they came in and took
photos like that you would be arrested
for child
abuse now you think they care about
national security risks
at the border the violent cartels that
are making money they're making a bundle
hand over fist
for democrats this is nothing more than
a pr crisis
only and in the end it's worth it for
them apparently because they do nothing
to solve it
they won't even acknowledge it like they
didn't acknowledge the riots over the
summer
the left seems to believe that open
borders means oh
more democratic voters we'll give them
something of great value amnesty
we just hope they vote for us now just
take a look at this gleeful pandering
from the first lady
when we come together we are powerful
with love for our communities with hope
for our future
with faith in each other anything is
possible
so say it with me si se puadre
the future is ours thank you
ah nailed it as you can see everything
democrats do
everything they say every bill they
enact or
through executive fiat and the stroke of
a pen
every group they pander to it is all a
shameless attempt to use your money so
they can gain power
hopefully in their minds in perpetuity
but buckle up you better brace
yourselves
if they are successful this democratic
socialism
like every other socialist experiment
before
it will fail it will destroy the us
united states of america as we know it